I want you to come back to Shh
after you did your review questions and
immediately you wrote a bunch of
derivatives and the corresponding
integrals do you member that can you go
to where that is on your page right at
the start of today's lesson and then we
wrote this and we were like like what do
we do with this okay
now I want to tie up that loose thread
for you now this is really important
because you might have noticed some of
the questions we did during this lesson
leaned towards it but don't quite lay it
out for you one of the tricky things in
math is often a question you know how to
do is just written in a form that makes
it look weird and awkward for example
one better
I think Shan Bobby maybe you and I were
looking at was something like this
correct me if I'm wrong something like
that something like this right
now this doesn't look like this doesn't
look like something you know how to do
except you all do because this cos
squared on the denominator a way to
write it that makes it more readily
obvious is by using a trig identity what
sugar Denney helps us write a reciprocal
it's in this case the reciprocal of cos
which is it's sick right so this is
actually how the question should be
written right and your letter I know how
to deal with that okay
now the same thing happens here except
it's gonna look weird because I'm gonna
make it look worse before it looks
better
I'm 10 X is an abbreviation it's a trig
identity itself what's in an
abbreviation for sine over cos now
normally normally we would say well why
would you write it like this it takes
more time it's extra but the point is
it's like this we're not quite there yet
this is a better form to make it clear
to us that we actually do know how to
integrate this okay this is a fraction
I've written it in a fraction to call to
mind the kinds of integrals you know how
to deal with that are fractions right
we've been dealing with these okay now
what we want is something that looks
like f dash or an F right now
this this is the F we're dealing with
right now
okay what's the F - that corresponds to
it it's negative sign isn't it be
careful the negatives flying around very
is it confused the derivative of this is
negative sign do I have that on the
numerator no I don't but that's okay
because I can make it a negative if
provided I compensate with another
negative two negatives make that
positive you're good with me so far so
now that that's the f dash that I want
do you agree there's F - so now I'm good
to go
I'm in exactly this form so let's do it
and I'd love you to write this with me
right what happens this minus sign at
the front just it just it just hangs out
there right just hangs out this is f
dash on F so it's integral is log of f
of X there it is right there plus my
constant of integration okay so you can
see it was kind of hiding and playing
say it was bit cheeky of us to not tell
you right out the front but it's quite
difficult to wrap your head around all
the signs in causing science science the
go with the signs so I didn't want to
show you this right away but you can see
this is similar cut similar what's the
walk around to what we've covered before
so long as you can learn to see it in a
way the telephone okay by the way um
actually is that on the reference sheet
I don't know that it is it's not because
it's the combination of this and all of
your knowledge of trigonometry so being
you can combine those together to get
this letter give it to you straight away
okay